fasting yeah how often do you do
long-term fasts like over like three
days or more and maybe that's not that
I'm a time you do it for basically how
often do you do them and how many days
do you do them for and can you explain
someone like the benefits like we're a
little low hanging fruit per se benefits
to to a human to practice these kind of
fasts yeah for fasting well I became
interested in fasting because of the
work that George Cahill did at Harvard
Medical School where he fasted subjects
for 40 days and this was published and I
kind of delved in and read everything I
could and that was sort of my
introduction probably going back to 2008
like reading this paper and then a big
review was written about him in 2006
which I was aware of but didn't really
read it thoroughly until 2008 then it
became apparent to me that once your
body is after about three days I mean
your your brain is basically your body's
just cranking on ketones so which is
being released from your fat stores so
your fat gets into your blood it goes to
your liver your brain can't really use
the fast refuel so it converts from the
ketones and there's a gradual shift from
glucose to ketones so I became very
interested in in doing it myself and it
was probably about again about 10 years
ago after reading this that I decided to
fast for seven days and I've never
fasted that long since but I have done a
lot of three day fast especially when
I'm traveling if I'm by myself my wife
and I like to sit down to dinner every
night and have that so sometimes you
know I do the intermittent fasting but I
only typically when I'm by myself or
doing some kind of experiment why do
three or four days and sometimes if I'm
sick too if I feel something coming on
I'll fast and go I never get sick really
so I believe you know fasting can
rejuvenate the immune system seventy
percent or more of your immune systems
kind of in your gut and a lot of immune
system energy is spent dealing with the
stuff that we're eating right so
especially if you have leaky gut so
you're eating food
and say your guts not in the best health
right the tight junctions that hold the
epithelial cells together and your gut
and they become loose or whatever you're
letting small particles and things get
into your bloodstream that otherwise
would not be there and your immune
system has to work they recognize these
these things as antigens so your immune
system is working hard to neutralize
some of these antigens right when you're
fasting your immune system is like it's
like looking for something to do right
so it's like hanging out so if you have
a little bug or a virus or something
then it becomes more vigilant to
basically deal with that so that's how I
think of it okay now but after I've been
delving into like how does fasting
affect a music so the way I envision it
and I'm not an immunologist but it's
very apparent that you know food it puts
massive demands especially if your gut
health is not optimal on your means even
if you have optimal gut health and
everything a lot of time and energy is
spent a lot of a lot of immunological
resources are spent dealing you know
with food so fasting is a way to sort of
regenerate the immune system it
stimulates things like otology right
which could be beneficial calorie
restriction could sort of do the same
thing but fasting does it sort of in a
hyper activated state so it can improve
your metabolic health it can lower you
know insulin lower blood glucose elevate
ketones which can be beneficial fasting
can be a way of sort of just maintaining
your calories like through intermittent
fasting but long-term fasting really
puts the body into a state of stress and
the hormetic response or adapter's
response to that stress is where we get
the benefits you know you might feel
good when you're fasting you might have
a headache you might feel crummy but
after if people stick with it after
about the third or fourth day you start
feeling almost normal it's a little bit
scary and and actually at the seventh
day I felt fine I just felt my energies
were kind of low I felt a little bit
cold like you know the a/c was too cold
like my metabolism was shutting down but
I was still clear I was writing grants
and actually the work that I did during
that time that grant and
getting funded and I think I got a
couple manuscripts out during the Wow
that I didn't eat anything you know did
I taught classes and stuff too did I
hear correctly that you dead lifted an
absurd amount of weight after like a
seven day fast yeah that was on the
seventh day yeah I think I'd taught in
the morning and I did some like fitness
camp later in the day and that night you
know I knew I was like well let me work
out I'd done some light workouts or just
like chin ups and push ups throughout
because I do think it's important to do
resistance training if you're fasting
you know maintain muscle but if you do
something too strenuous right you're
accelerating catabolic processes and you
don't want to necessarily do that but I
did find it very interesting as a litmus
test for my strength strength deadlifts
were pretty good litmus test for that
and and I was kind of cautious not to go
too crazy because I didn't want to break
form and get injured at the at the end
of this definitely like really bad like
don't but you know as you're warming up
you have an idea of how much you know so
it's like 135 225 and 315 and then 405
felt really easy and then so I did like
five plates and the collars and stuff so
I was about 500 pounds and yeah I did
that for ten I just kind of stopped at
ten and I didn't you know really feel I
didn't even get sore the next day or
anything like that but I can typically
do more but as I didn't push myself so
maybe I could do 585 at that time for
about ten so he did Wow 95 or 500 pounds
so I usually do like six plates for 10
but at five players per ten and it was
not hard it was about how it normally
feels okay so that that was kind of if I
was to do it again I would take
something like creatine monohydrate I
would probably that's like a supplement
you know that can help with with
training I would probably take I did
take electrolytes but I do plan to do it
again I just need to time it right you
know with I don't I feel like I'm master
sizing my wife I'm not eating dinner I'm
like that more of a social thing I think
when I was doing it before I would just
like have tea like green tea in the
morning I tried to cut back on my
caffeine yeah that's that's one of my
important I really had for you was
during those long term fasts of what do
you you can do you have tea do you drink
what specific things do you consume
a beef bouillon cubes I had those I
would make I would just boil some water
and throw it one in and that was
actually like pretty satiating I would
look forward to that but uh I would I
would have half of my normal cup of
coffee because I didn't want to Jack
myself up on caffeine but I didn't want
to eliminate it because that was part of
I'm habituated to caffeine you know
whether you like it or not that's I
think we all are I we wake up and have
our first cup of coffee to basically
deal with the caffeine withdrawal side
effects yeah
when I first started training I used
caffeine like twice a week and the
effects were pretty big but I didn't
want to completely get off of it and
then start caffeine again so I just did
less of it with green tea in the
afternoon but that's all I had
minerals electrolytes um beef bouillon
and I felt fine I think the third day
was the hardest but after that it was
pretty easy and I encourage people to do
it especially if they have any kind of
you know hereditary you know
predisposition for cancer Alzheimer's
disease or type 2 diabetes things like
that
[Laughter]